Michael how are you I found something
really interesting the whole housing
market is propped up on these bad loans
they will fail the housing market is
rock solid that's a time bomb so Mike
burry who gets his hair cut
Supercuts and doesn't wear shoes knows
more than Alan Greenspan dr. Mike burry
yes he does
you know what I'm pissed off American
people we're getting screwed by the big
banks and I am getting madder and madder
it's unbelievable then this guy walks
into my office and says there's some
shady stuff going down
while the banks we're having a big old
party a few outsiders saw where no one
else could world economy might collapse
I'm sure the world's banks have more
dissensions agreed you're wrong no one's
paying attention the bank's got greedy
and we can profit off of their stupidity
you want to bet against the banks to
think we're either high or having a
stroke kind of brilliant fraud has never
ever worked eventually things go south
when the hell did we forget all that
how can the banks let this happen it's
fueled by stupidity but that's not
stupidity that's fraud tell me the
difference between stupid and illegal
and I'll have my wife's brother arrested
you have any idea what you just did you
just bet against the American economy if
you're wrong you can loose it all the
banks and defraud the American people
now we can take over the team okay here
we go
we target strippers it's bad loans you
need no cash rich oh I'm not going to be
able to refinance on all my loans what
do you mean all your loan
I have five houses in the condo
you